bonjour mon amant anne-marie où elle est
mère d'un enfant de 8 mois termine son
congé de maternité dans moins de deux
semaines
malgré ses nombreuses recherches
l'infirmière auxiliaire pour les sud de
la capitale nationale n'a pas trouvé de
garderie on va se prendre avec les la
famille même si c'est par recommandé par
monsieur legault la belle maman ou grand
maman va prendre bébé après ce masseur
mon père aussi
si certains parents trouvent des
solutions d'autres sont obligés de
travailler à temps partiel
jessica dumont infirmières pour les sus
de l'estrie travail de nuit
son retour à l'emploi est prévue en mars
c'est ce que de nombreux parents je me
trouve font ces dernières dans une porte
fermée à chaque match chaque instant
donc toujours une toujours aucune
possibilité aux tentes rappelant qu'à
temps partiel
le manque de places en garderie n'est
pas nouveau dans la province mais la
crise sanitaire à exacerber le problème
un minus de la famille lui même le dit
nous sommes donc c'est de leur trouver
des solutions à court terme entre le 1er
mars et le 31 octobre 2020 plus de 800
garderie en milieu familial ont fermé
leurs portes ces trois cents de plus que
l'année précédente et ce bilan ne tient
pas compte des fermetures temporaires en
raison de la pandémie
j'invite le gouvernement fluxus cette
problématique là qu'un impact sur la
relance économique
saleh n'est pas du tout la santé mentale
des parents aussi
nous aurons la première vague les
travailleurs essentiels avait accès à
des places dans des garderies d'urgence
mais avec la réouverture de toutes les
installations
le service n'est plus possible moi mes
collègues qui sont à bout de souffle on
le voit par tous les médias sociaux
onze mille places en cpe sont en
développement mais les parents doivent
prendre leur mal en patience
on se demande comment aller travailler
qui va prendre soin de rendre le plus
précieux au monde
ben ça q de l'enquêté donc il les
comprend bien mais j'ai envie de leur
dire que
on est au travail qu'on veut régler la
situation en attendant l'arrivée de
nouvelles places en cpe
le gouvernement compte lancer une
campagne de valorisation du métier
d'éducatrice et miser sur les milieux
familiaux ici pas ni samson radio canada
québec